cuz I'm going to have a car
[Music]
rolling stone once called John Prine the
Mark Twain of American songwriting Bryan
died yesterday in Nashville from
complications of the coronavirus he was
73 prime received a Lifetime Achievement
Award at the Grammys earlier this year
his brilliant songs are still with us
along with the respect he earned from
other music greats new windows John
Prine was a gifted storyteller whose
songs were hailed by peers like Bob
Dylan as Midwestern mine trips to the
enth degree I get my mail in Tennessee
my wife my dog my kids and me crimes
tunes have been sung by Bette Midler
Johnny Cash some stones welcome home and
Bonnie Raitt's
last year rates sang that country
classic with him at the Americana annual
honors Brian grew up outside of Chicago
after a stint in the army he became a
mailman writing songs as he delivered
letters he was just 23 when a glowing
review from film critic Roger Ebert
launched his career in 1970 from that
day on I didn't have an empty c-prime
survived cancer twice and when I
interviewed the singer-songwriter in
2018 for CBS Sunday morning he just
released his first album of new songs in
13 years are you enjoying this
resurgence tip 7 45 years to get the job
I think simply they're getting it now
and I'm still around to reap the
benefits
sometimes my Ojai
is like a washing machine he celebrated
the release with a sold-out show at
Radio City Music Hall then as God is my
witness I'm getting back into show
business we may have lost John Prine to
coronavirus but this is the way I prefer
to remember him leaving us dancing a jig
to one of his own songs Lake Murray in
2018 our condolences to his wife Fiona
and their kids Jodi Jack and Tommy bruce
springsteen said last night on twitter
he was a true national treasure and a
songwriter for the ages and boy that's
the truth I don't know anyone who had
more respect in the songwriting
community than he did he had a whole Jun
generation of acolytes like Kacey
Musgraves and Dan Auerbach of the Black
Keys people just loved him and we will
miss him very much I'll say Anthony he
was beloved in the music industry not
only for his music but they say he was
such a great guy and you got to spend
time with him yeah it's you know he's a
John Prine never wanted fame and glory
he just wanted to live an all ordinary
life and and write some songs and he
wrote really some of the best he will be
missed Thank You Anthony